hey I'm Jada pinkett-smith and this is
the wired
autocomplete interview alright what is
Jada pinkett-smith zodiac sign
I am a Virgo to the core what college
did Jada pinkett-smith attend I went to
North Carolina School for the Arts drama
specifically where does Jada
pinkett-smith live in Baltimore oh I
can't tell you that
I still got family there where is Jada
pinkett-smith where's her mom from my
mom's from Baltimore Baltimore Maryland
she still lives there as well as my
aunts and cousins and yeah so we're
still deep in Baltimore when did Jada
pinkett-smith get married I got married
23 years ago in Baltimore how about that
because will was making oh gosh what
movie was he making it was the Tony
Scott movie that he was in I can never
remember the man's movies he's done so
many what does Jada pinkett-smith look
like now I look like this Ken Jada
pinkett-smith sing can she see it's a
pencil who you ask
I like metal music I can't say that I
did a whole lot of singing in metal well
I did I did it's like melodic metal I
would say that willow has the better
voice though when's Jada Pinkett Smith's
birthday September 18th I have one
coming up you guys make sure you wish me
happy birthday okay okay
what's Jada pinkett-smith height when I
have on heels I'm probably five to two
maybe depending on the height of the
heel but with with no heels I'm probably
like 5 feet maybe 411 yeah I'm a shorty
shorty with a big spirit though I walk
tall
okay did Jada pinkett-smith know to pop
yes I did very well all right
does Jada pinkett-smith speak Spanish I
do speak Spanish and when I'm really on
top of it I do well but it's something
you have to do every day or it leaves
you so I keep saying to myself that I'm
just gonna go live like in Mexico or in
the Dominican and learn Spanish like
just fluent Floyd Floyd and stay there
for six months or something I really
need to do that
those Jada pinkett-smith have tattoos I
do I have this one that's fading on my
wrist I have three dots and a heart with
three lines and both of the tattoos
represent my children Willow Jaden and
Trey does Jada pinkett-smith have a book
I do I wrote a children's book called we
girls hold up the world many many years
ago I might do a read table talk book so
if I do a book that would be the one
that you'll you'll see does Jada
pinkett-smith have a college degree I
don't I went to college for a year I'm a
college dropout sorry after my freshman
year I said mom I can either go to
college to become a lawyer or I can go
to Hollywood and see if I can really
make it in this business
and she said off to Hollywood we go did
Jada pinkett-smith die I'll let you
answer that is Jada Pinkett Smith a
doctor na is Jada Pinkett Smith a vegan
is Jada Pinkett Smith in a band I was I
was in a metal band called wicked wisdom
I was in that metal band for many many
many years we did lots of tours with
other great metal bands and we did the
Ozzfest we've done a whole bunch of tour
so I had a good time with that part of
my life is Jada Pinkett Smith related to
Zoe Saldana that's so funny because
everybody thinks we look alike and if
you see pictures of us next to each
other we actually could be cousins or
sisters but we're not family I wish coz
I just love her to dust she's such a
sweetie
how does Jada pinkett-smith stay in
shape well I stay very active I have a
very physically active life I also work
out on a gym not as aggressively as I
used to
it's really all about what you eat so my
my diet is pretty
it doesn't seem strict to me but I think
other people looking at what I eat would
say this is nonsense I eat pretty much
the same thing every day
how did Jada pinkett-smith become famous
I think just over the years and I think
it's more just about the longevity that
I've had and the projects that I've done
and I would also say being a part of a
really well-known family and part of a
well-known marriage all of that tends to
help with the famous thing so how old in
menace to society how old am i menace to
society I'm a baby a menace to society
that's 20 all you little young
thunderkittens out there 20 now I'm a
Thundercat you're Thunder kitten but I
thought it was a Thundercat at 20 I'm
just realizing now as a baby
how is Jada pinkett-smith related to
Jordan Woods you know what Jordan was
and I are actually not related
she's just been part of our family since
she was an infant her dad worked with
will on the Fresh Prince
I've known Jordan literally since she
was in her mommy's tummy how many movies
has Jada pinkett-smith been in oh man I
don't know how many but it's been a lot
I'm not quite sure that it the exact
number though that's a lot okay we got
one more guys let's see who is Jada
Pinkett Smith's best friend I have a lot
of good friends I dare not say that one
of them is my best friend you get me
into a lot of trouble I'm trying to
think who one of my best friends that
you would know one of them is MC Lyte do
you know who MC Lyte is she's iconic rap
artist she's my girl
who is Jada pinkett-smith sister I don't
have a sister but I do have a brother
his name is Caleb Pinkett we share the
same father and we are both pink it's to
the core whoo Jada pinkett-smith eye
color they change up sometimes it Browns
sometimes they're like light brown
sometimes they're green believe it or
not it's like a mood ring my eyes willow
has the same eyes but they change up I
don't know where they come from I have
no idea nobody else in our family has
them it's just the two of us somewhere
back back in the day somebody back there
gave them to us so that's it thanks wire
thank you for coming and hanging out
thank you for all these questions I had
a good time